okay come on Nate how did how did this
happen
I know well we I don't think we've ever
really like us here I don't think we
ever had a cross path uh they knew it is
crazy and we have in the fact of like I
think work but it's uh not a ton I don't
know just like around I feel like we
never crossed paths like um past like
festivals like yeah I stopped doing
festivals a long time ago I feel like
because I was just like why am I flying
to Canada to get paid a thousand dollars
to bomb for my agents like what am I
doing like I stopped doing festivals and
I feel like that's when you Comics that
live in different places really like
kind of meet yeah yeah it's the best I
mean that that is the fun part of
festivals that's the lure to go back to
them is because you're like you gotta go
see because you're you're with like I
mean just all the people you don't get
to see anymore right right and so you
see them then it's just kind of a trip
like have you ever just run into a
comedian that you've never met in an
airport oh yeah and you like you're like
and you start talking as if you've known
each other for 30 years yeah you really
do just jump into it because it's weird
because you've both been doing the same
thing like I know you're me and Giannis
I know you you're the best yeah me and
Giannis started saved my life quite
literally broke up a pitbull fight that
I was in the middle of yeah oh wow yeah
I saved my nose like nostril and mouth
he was staying with me and I had two pit
bulls that were going at each other over
like a puppy like a rescue situation and
uh he's the only man I think I've ever
had in my house that
was wearing sneakers he wears sneakers
until he goes to bed there's no
flip-flops there's no Barefoot there's
no socks and at like midnight I'm in a
pitbull fight he hears it Sprints I mean
the like like breaks it up like saves my
life yeah any other man would have been
in like um I don't know tivas or uh
would have not been able to do it yeah
he's just like a man in ways that I I
love him so much as a brother but like
in that moment he made me realize I
think I cannot be with someone unless
they wear sneakers
like a man has to wear sneakers at all
times I if this is only this sounds like
the uh I would think that would describe
you as a person is someone that would be
in a pitbull fight at midnight and I
don't know I try to say in a mean way
but if someone if they go what is
Whitney like
I'd like you know I wasn't fighting the
pimples but just I mean just near it in
it I mean just you you if a pit bull
fighting is having a midnight I I would
imagine ah you're you're either in it or
you're around it or you can get to it so
um Giannis
started together
yeah we've been we've been me and you
honestly have a podcast
a long time ago back on podcasts where
uh before they were released something
yeah and we had one called it could be
better
and uh with Chris Laker and be honest we
never come to the podcast because
Giannis this is Giannis maurisa is
happening uh and it's he's selling out
like God I did just listen to the
episode of your podcast where you
returned after being gone for a while
yeah well it was it was because he like
Giannis would like I would tell him I
was like we should be I was like you got
it because I even then you know like
podcasts were like I think Marinette is
but it was like they weren't all going
crazy yet but it's like it was like you
know in New York it was still like a lot
of New York Comics if you're like I'm
gonna start a podcast they're like just
do comedy dude you loser can I ask you a
wild question like what makes you decide
to have a podcast with a certain person
because I know a lot of people that are
really good friends Comics that don't
have podcasts together and a lot of her
friends that um uh Comics that had them
and it like ruined their friendship like
how did you like how do you pick the
person you're gonna do it is like kind
of more um serious than getting married
I mean yeah it is well we were just uh
we're I mean we're we're very close and
uh we were very different I'm from the
south he's from my podcast is called
nateland and that's coming from that's a
Giannis name Giannis came up with that
because he would say whenever he leaves
New York it's night land it's just dudes
with hats
he would do that so that's where Nate
Lane came from meanwhile Giannis is
sunburned at all times oh it's like just
try a hat just try it see what happens
they're they're Giannis I'd always say
because he would do uh he would also
like I don't have any culture and all
this stuff and he make fun of that but
then I was like but he lived three
blocks from his mom like you know it's
like you're like well I mean what
culture do you have you lived in
Brooklyn your whole life you just
because other people I get like a lot of
cultures live in Brooklyn but you've
never really left this area and you
lived a woman what could she possibly
teach you yeah yeah yeah it is this then
he moved he moved to Miami but we
started when we did it he was like
starting to do Marisa and it was like
yeah I knew you had to commit to it it's
like you got to be able to you gotta you
need to have it needs to come out every
week at this time and like you gotta you
gotta do that kind of stuff and he just
wasn't uh he didn't feel like you know I
think it was just hard and like no you
know was like who knew what these
podcasts were gonna
what it was gonna eventually become
[Music]
this show is brought to you by better
help it's so brutal most therapy that I
gone to before better help why would you
put yoga magazines on a coffee table in
a therapist office your woman just look
at people that are more flexible and
thinner and happier than me
is that helpful I you it seems like you
have some eating issues I didn't
before I had to read all your yoga
monthlies doing therapy online has been
such a game changer okay discover your
potential visit betterhelp.com you can
change therapists at any time okay
within 24 hours you can find a therapist
that works for you you're also going to
get a hot deal with Slash
whitneybetterhelp.com Whitney today to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp aglp.com Whitney this will
change your life I love you guys
betterhealth.com Whitney government of
New York and uh when people didn't have
their driver's license and so like you
could you'd go on a gig and you're like
are you gonna drive and they're like I
don't know how to drive you know and
you're
like there's people that'd be like 40
and don't have a driver's license and
you're like what Andrew Schultz every
time he comes to my home it's like a
40-minute Saga at the front gate because
he can't pull the I have a like a call
box and he can't get the car up to the
call box to do to put his to hit the
buttons it's like a whole and then we
went to somewhere where we had to get a
ticket out of a machine to go in a
garage and it was like a whole like New
Yorkers like
I think you guys think you're a little
tougher than you are you know what I
mean like I just yeah they don't do it
well they have you get in a car you're
getting uh you're you're just getting
into things yeah you're getting into
things that move you around yeah yeah
you're not driving yeah yeah yeah that's
really interesting I think New York's
trying to I feel like they're gonna try
to get to where they're there's no
driving there
or like it's just cabs or it's like
interesting the cabs have gone away I
feel like that's really sad yeah you
know well they gotta adjust them and
they got the Ubers and then uh
Cavs will get you get in fights with
cabs or however because I live in Queens
and see if you land in LaGuardia and
take a cabin home they would be furious
because they wanted to go to Manhattan
and so then you would and I mean it
would be the most uncomfortable but you
tell them once you got in don't you have
to tell them before you get in because
in New York yeah they know but they know
but like in the when you get out of the
airport like the cabs are in that line
so you go I need a cab and you go on the
line and then they just put you in the
cab and when you tell that cab I'm going
to Queens he's not happy I I don't know
how I learned this I think it's because
I think it's at four o'clock the cabs
switch over right so the ones that are
going uptown going downtown at like four
o'clock they're about to be off duty you
can only be going they'll only pick you
up if you're going downtown and then
vice versa right for some reason I don't
know how I learned maybe I was like
burned yeah um in this way where I I say
where I'm going before I even get in
yeah I thought that was the thing yeah
because yeah I like doing that did you
say I want you to wrap your head around
what's happening
like I want everybody to know I need you
to think this over before I get in your
I need you to make sure
um you can do this I don't want to be
uncomfortable
that's because that that's I like I mean
I remember getting in with them because
of the Queen's thing because they want
to make the money to go to the Manhattan
but then uh and they end up giving them
something that they can come back
through but they would just be so mad
and they would make you feel it and
you're like are you mad at me because I
don't
right I'm not a trillionaire that can
live in Manhattan like right right right
right if they don't even be in this case
yes you so you want me to be an asshole
that can afford to live in Manhattan
yeah you're like what do you want me to
do dude at least just so you know next
year I will have your job probably like
we'll be in the like yeah I'm coming I'm
trying to get your job yeah I'll how
about this next time when you need I'll
drive you next time when I'm in the line
I would do a car service like even like
just a queen's like a local car service
yeah just to avoid
the the stress of like I I because it
happens so much that I was like I just
don't want to deal with like the guy mad
at me because I don't live far enough
from the airport what's up Zach doc can
we rock is that a song thousands of
medical professionals are on ZocDoc to
help you they're there to listen like a
friend give you the expert care you need
there are better ways to get the answers
you want and the care you deserve from
trusted professionals and not random
people on the inner internet you find
the doctor that's right for you
completely seamless quality care you
need in just a few Taps away in the zoc
doc app ZocDoc is the only free app that
lets you find and book doctors who are
patient reviewed take your insurance are
available when you need them and treat
almost every condition Under the Sun
including melanoma surprise twists might
work for podcasts but maybe not for
medical care with ZocDoc there are no
alarms no surprises no drama choose from
thousands of patient review doctors
specialist browse doctors profiles is
this a dating site is there oh my God
ZocDoc should have like a dating
section
is sexual healing involved in this jkjk
upload and verify your insurance
information and get the care you need go
to zocdoc.com Whitney and download the
ZocDoc app for free and book the top
rated doctor today many are available
within 24 hours and many might be single
that sockdoc.com Whitney
zocdoc.com Whitney zocdoc.com Whitney
now go read a book idiot
sir so many questions for you long
overdue I don't even really know where
to start however I just want to say I am
I am like wildly uh like you watching
your life special it made me like
rethink everything I was like why am I
like are you ever do you ever get a
place in um uh into a place as a
performer where you're doing something
and then you see someone great in your
field do something and you're like
hold on wait let's let's like can I
start over you know what I mean in your
your work really makes me do that
because it's very nice you you take very
um for lack of a better word you know I
think it's it's an incredible skill to
to be you have to be incredibly smart to
be simple sometimes and I think Comics
like sometimes our instinct is over
complicate things and we miss what's
truly interesting about it because we're
trying to think of the most like
cerebral thing but the most clever take
is just saying
the simplest thing that everybody
acknowledges like did you in the
beginning ever struggle with over
complicating things before you got to
just like the gem that you were trying
to like mine out yeah yeah you think of
it uh well you always think they get it
like the audience is not dumb and that's
where you didn't talk about the LA and
the South Middle Country thing so it's
like it happens with TV and you watch TV
and they they think the audience is dumb
and so they think in those rooms well
are they gonna get is Middle America
gonna get
they're gonna get anything that you put
out and so you gotta always you know
it's like when you go to Canada and
you're like are they gonna understand
Walmart you're like yeah dude they're
gonna know what Walmart and you're gonna
look stupid that's correct trying to go
I love it so Walmart you guys know
Walmart right yeah you guys you took a
store in this third world country I'm in
you guys have heard of Walmart right
okay yeah so that's what it's like you
got to do that stuff and that's that's
the part that separates like you watch a
lot of TV now
and and I the one thing that helped me
is I was always like uh I'm being from
Tennessee when I moved to New York it
was like I never tried to like I don't
know I just I loved being from Tennessee
I loved being at home I loved like I
didn't you know he was I was magic magic
magic it's great and I was maybe very
naive to like I just never thought
anything bad about it or whatever but I
loved New York and I loved all that
stuff uh but it was you know like you
watch TV and all this stuff you just get
to where like they're making shows and
they're doing stuff and you're like
they're just not making it for the
people they're in Tennessee they're
making it you can tell now too that
they're making the people that are
making it are like well y'all just live
here and you're only talking about your
circumstances and then so then that's
where stuff becomes being relatable is
like something that's kind of being
forgot about I mean they're you know I
always thought about it uh when I worked
uh before I started comedy I read water
meters uh like at a for Wilson County I
remember a guy that we worked with that
didn't know like if you could he thought
you could drive to Hawaii like just
never he would think that but then
before he got to work it was like he'd
be like oh yeah or you know uh our cow
had babies this morning so and then he
like did that this morning it's a
difference and he could like live off
the grid and you're like so it's like a
guy like that that you're like oh he
could live off the grid he doesn't know
if you drive to Hawaii but like when
Putin hits the nuclear yeah yeah you're
like yo dude what are you doing yeah do
you want to hang out go to his house and
he know that's the smartest stuff that's
the craziest stuff ever yeah that he
knows because that's like I I'm obsessed
with like how like to be a scientist you
have to go like pay three hundred
thousand dollars to go to a a university
that is just give telling you the
science that was true whatever so if a
scientific study comes out today right
that means it was true three years ago
right because that's when the study was
done it took this long to put it
together so scientific studies I feel
like are always like three years behind
on some level you know what I mean and
no one I just feel like if you're a
scientist like in your is it smart to
spend three hundred thousand dollars to
learn how to be like I just am kind of
like it blows my mind because I think
that like there's a way to be sort of
like a uh like a common sense scientist
you know a lot of the people I know that
just have like the wisdom that only
comes with age and like Southern wisdom
I feel I'm like you're so much smarter
than any of well you need like both you
need like that 300 000 person to maybe
go fact check it but then you also like
can we have a person in front that's
like yeah yeah like this is how it is
and then we're letting we're gonna live
life because I believe it's this yeah
and then this person can make sure like
to you know they don't know that you can
get tap water and leave it out for 24
hours and then you can drink it like
little things like that you know like
remember did you ever used to get
goldfish and you'd have to leave the
water out for 24 hours
and then it was clean was that real
I don't know I've never heard of that
yeah like just like little things like
the other day I sprouted peanuts and
everyone was like in Hollywood the most
successful people I know they're like
how did you do that did you like like
did someone come teach you how to do it
I was like not it it's like a pretty
easy thing like people in Hollywood they
have a person they're like well my my B
guys coming over uh to clean out the hot
I'm like why don't you just learn how to
do it when you when you get so much
money you you just become disconnected
from any sort of reality and like so you
don't I would always say you just put
you should have normal people in your
life and like when you're out and when
you don't you gotta have like you know
your friends from high school you need
your yeah if you're gonna go uh you're
gonna go to Puerto Rico tomorrow you
need someone that goes I mean I have to
work every day so I don't know what you
do that's my favorite and you gotta like
someone that's safe reminding that like
you they're not living the lifestyle or
like even have the free nine the money
but even just the freedom like you know
a Comics like we're used to you know
being like all right let's go get
breakfast at noon and then or 11 or noon
and then you because our lifestyles just
our times are like this and you need
someone that's like if you ask me at
breakfast at 11 they're like I mean
they're they're eating lunch and they're
like no dude I woke up at like in L.A
work starts at 10.
yeah across the board like business work
people ask me they're like how did you
get your success I'm like I literally
just start work at like 8 30. yeah so
everyone else starts at 10 so I have
like literally 15 years of an extra hour
a day so that's just how I got ahead
yeah I just like worked an eight-hour
day in Hollywood instead of like a two
hour I mean because people here they
start work at 10 they go to lunch at
noon it's literally the hours are less
than like a doctor's office you know
like doctor's office they're like we're
open from like 7 30 to 8 30 and then 11
to 11 30 and then like three to four and
like that's it you know and then you're
gonna voice screen like that's the same
as Hollywood it's a miracle actually
anything gets done because it's like
there was a um they take off for every
holiday too I mean every the holidays
it's not your holidays anymore it's like
I'm taking two weeks off for um a silent
Retreat uh I have to do bonding leave
with my new Rescue puppy like it's like
I have acupuncture like it's like not
even holidays anymore at this point
because also by the way these are very
people that are trying to cancel
holidays yeah they're like Columbus
day's over Flag Day toxic like we got to
get rid of you know uh whatever Robert E
Lee day I don't know what other days are
getting everybody really dead three
times ago that's it these are like
another southern day you're like well
that's a pretty big day for us you know
Robert E Lee day it's everyday bitch but
it's just like there's some like I think
Martin Luther King he cheated on his
wife yeah are we still allowed to
celebrate this and you're like y'all the
people that like leave at 2 15 you know
for a six hour lunch but it there is a
there was a um like a thing that came
out that was like about uh how a few
days you work in hot people in Hollywood
actually work because they uh leave
basically after Thanksgiving which
you're not supposed to celebrate because
the we Slaughter the natives but we will
take off two weeks yeah they do leave
after we're going to publicly say on
Instagram like this holiday is toxic and
this is disgusting and I will be out of
the office for two and a half weeks
because I'm going to and it's good
mid-January if I think about it and then
and then they go straight to finance and
then it's the Oscars and then it's San
Sebastian then it's Berlin and then it
goes out they're never well and that's
where too the money aspect too is where
everybody gets money this money is like
made up into like it's just this ungodly
amount of money it costs to make these
things and then the money is just spread
yeah yeah like who knows where it goes
and all this I do yeah I know where it
goes yeah
yeah like um it's it's pretty wild I
mean it's it's it's it's a it's a trip I
want to ask you though are you ever like
actively trying to turn your brain off
or did these like observations do they
kind of hit you and creep up on you like
like do you know right away so you're at
like you know Cracker Barrel whatever
you go by the candle section and you're
like okay this is gonna be the thing you
know are you actively I I'm gonna admit
it it's embarrassing I feel like I am
always looking yeah yeah I've never like
oh here's a candle I'm gonna buy this
candle I'm always like this okay like
I'm always digging for something yeah
yeah it never turns off it's exhausting
and it's it just especially right now
because I the special's out so then I
had to come up with a new hour and so
you're just now just like you get in a
panic mode and but I don't there's no I
don't have a system I don't know what
the system is I wish there was a system
that I could rely on like I'm uh I it's
just pure panic of like you know every
time is I don't know if I know how to do
do this I don't put pressure on yourself
well but I truly don't know you're like
I don't know how to do this like I don't
you know because it's hard to be like
well you're like I knew how to do that
hour I don't know if I know how to do my
another one another like another what am
I going to talk about there's nothing to
talk about and I think I really like to
like after my fourth special I took
um like six months off of at least
performing because I was like I just
want to get I wanna I just want to make
sure I'm not like doing an impression of
myself because I kind of always feel
like by the time you shoot the hour
you're sort of already grown past it a
little bit you know what I mean you're
like yeah that's about the time you
shoot is when you start like by the time
I shoot it I'm just like I never want to
say any of that like I have not been
that person I've not I don't even know
if I've believed that for the past
couple months sure I'm saying but it is
working but I just am like so like want
to get it away from me so badly
um and then uh uh this this time around
is the first time ever that I feel like
just you know what really is just like
soothing about stand up even though it's
so hard to figure out like am I good am
I getting back better my plateauing is
like I think after like I don't know 15
or 16 years if you've been doing it as
much as we have you can kind of just I
don't know I've built trust with myself
on stage finally like something broke
after the fifth special where I now can
like write on stage and my special came
out the last one a little bit faster
than I thought it would and I had to
write a new hour in like a month and a
half and I absolutely did it yeah I did
it because I think that there used to be
this thing though where we were like an
hour takes a year to put together like I
don't I don't know I just feel like
there's a lot of things we heard said by
other comedians maybe before like email
and Google yeah that we were like and it
doesn't mean it's perfect and ready to
shoot but I was able to tour with it
yeah you know because I think it takes a
long time to get it tightened and get it
like it'll take me a year to get it
short up but I was able to kind of I was
still able to make people laugh for an
hour yeah you know yeah and then um uh
which is kind of just like fascinating
and I and I I'm able to do this like
smaller clubs which I love going back
and then so they kind of know what
you're doing and like like you know you
can kind of yeah that's always great I
just went to Comedy magic club like uh I
haven't been there in ages do they still
have magicians come out before uh they
didn't this time but they yeah I think
they do but it's like that it was great
because it was like I just got to go up
and that was a big big help because you
really need that I would take time off I
didn't I don't have really time off
after this one but the next one I'm
gonna make sure I have you know three
months or something or two months where
it's like it is that where you're like
maybe you have a show or something but
you're overall just you need to be at
home you need like I I like that's the
the big part is like you go I need I
just need to be home because then that's
where you're gonna come up with stuff
it's all it's you gotta go live a lot
you got to go live your life in order
for art to imitate life you have to have
a life yeah it's like so hard for us to
figure that out because like you see
like I'm terrified like not that I'm you
know at anywhere close to this level but
it's like you see
um you know comedians sometimes get
richer and richer and more successful
and then they stop being friends with
Comedians and you see them you're like
what are you doing yeah like what's like
like literally like oh so the other day
I was flying private and you're like
what are you doing oh yeah like what are
you lit you have to go to an airport now
for like five hours well that's why like
you living at least farther out and like
you got you need to get out of it you
can't be in because when you're in it
it's just it's your life and it's it's
got to be a weird balance and that's
about the social media social media the
same thing you got to be you need to be
on it but you also have to be able to
like get out of it you're making me
realize something that I I uh I think is
such an obstacle for comedians now which
is that you know I realize that I have
got to stay in love with people like we
can we can always I feel like find what
we're looking for right so if you're
only on the news and you're like ah all
people are monsters and all people are
this and then you just like you know get
in a cab and talk to a cool cab driver
and you're like oh okay I love making
people laugh nobody's monsters nobody
like oh nobody I I would say 95 percent
probably higher of people are awesome on
Earth awesome awesome so where do we get
I think it's from our from our um you
know primary caretakers like I got some
bad messages It's tricky because I think
a lot of comedians they grew up with
maybe a lot of parents that could be
monstery yeah you know so by the time
they move into the world they assume
everybody is but I have to actively and
I think Comics have to actively collect
contrary data in order to stay hopeful
and stay a good comic so it's like to me
it's like it's about the jokes whatever
but it's more about me being like I want
to go make these people laugh so bad
because they deserve it so badly well
your life can't be about you so it's how
do you know that well I I just know that
it can't your life if it's about you
it's not good it's got to be second like
being those are like with we're
Christian like uh you know from the
south Christian like my my parents are
very close with them still they're my
dad was your life's supposed to be about
uh you should be second to everybody
second to God second to other people
but it's the same you should be second
the second you make everything about you
is your life is going to be miserable
because you can't make everything you
want to be good but you need to be that
feeling of going to make that crowd
laugh your feeling should be about that
it shouldn't be like I'm trying to go
destroyed to move my career all those
things happen I'm not saying you're not
trying to do stuff but you but the
purpose needs to be about that audience
that audience is going through whatever
they're going through that audience is
looking needs a break that audience Your
Entertainment you're just entertainment
for them and it's about them and that's
a big thing that I think Hollywood has
missed out on everything they make is
not about it's about making the money or
they have to that's why they only make
these Giants not anymore it's not making
money anymore you guys are losing money
because you're not talking to the people
like yes yeah Hollywood like Adam
Sandler is the only like I went to just
went to the show he's it and you watched
when I watched his show everything about
him is what I want to be that guy goes
out there and makes that those movies
for the audience and that audience shows
up in rewards if you do it you will be
rewarded with everything that you want
to go do and his movies aren't like well
I mean his movies The Happy Madison
movies like he's he's going you guys are
smart I'm dumb yeah but we know that
even smart people want to laugh at dumb
shit sometimes dude when I tell you that
mall cop like
it's it makes I've gone into Hollywood
meetings and been like you guys like
it's it's it's you know Desperately
Seeking Susan meets mall cop and they're
always like Mall Cop I'm like it's one
of the funniest like him just it's
hilarious if you don't think that's
hilarious and then you're gonna go well
Dirty Rotten Scoundrels is masterpiece
like Mall Cop is
just um
hysterical yeah I fell off the
elliptical watching it with the sound
off yeah the gym ones yeah
thank you excellent that's how they
describe someone that watches Mall Cop
they go
if you can't figure out a treadmill this
is your movie yeah yeah yeah but it's
like I just I'm like the mall cop with
the sound off is funnier than the last
20 movies you guys made with the sound
on like I don't know what to tell you
they well they're not watching what
they're making and so are they you know
we I had uh uh One Pilot that was shot
which I am is this with Danielle yes
she's awesome the best but I'm a giant
fan of you with all that you've created
with like Two Broke Girls and you show
Whitney like and all that like I and you
and Roseanne like you're the the TV
aspect of like what you were able to do
just because I've tried to sell shows
for these but I'm trying doing that like
I've done it they've never really gone
but I know how hard it is I see how hard
it is to make these shows so by the time
you were doing it it was
uh over like there was just no um the
the business was collapsing you know I
think in a lot of ways uh Network TV
kind of feels a little bit like doing
Broadway as of right now yeah I mean The
Daily Show was is was getting 383 000
viewers yeah it's crazy you know what I
mean it's like our well that's what they
why don't they go back that's what
doesn't make sense is how do they not
why is Seinfeld in the office and
Raymond and Kevin and King Wings why are
these shows well Two Broke Girls why why
are people only watching those shows if
they're not watching the new shows
that's what like it's insane that they
don't really I mean think about it so
two were girls it was like you know
basically uh it's about
um things that I think you know Roseanne
remember the pilot um the first one
where they were talking about like you
know paying bills yeah God we're gonna
pay this to the electric We're not gonna
pay to this We're Not Gonna sign this
check you know that scene that
incredible scene in the pilot where
they're trying to figure out how Cosby
Show pilot was uh Theo uh doing the
money when cos when he sits down Theo
and tells them show me your money that
you got it right right right that's the
part that's one of the most scenes in
The Cosby Show and that's the pilot
correct and uh but that was about a real
a real situation I want to come back to
a Cosby thing in a second um well guys
it's just not the so I the yeah you know
he's a bad guy that's what you go back
to yeah I am like okay okay Theory I'm
working on hmm I think we can is this
one of those I want to ask to be cut out
of yeah
you can leave it in but just
just yeah I just
follow itself right you're not doing
stuff right now you have like a beef
jerky deal or something yeah yeah yeah
so um yeah
I'm gonna open this Diet Pepsi uh yes
that's for you actually oh I'm very
excited um
so Bill Cosby what he did was bad bad
naughty naughty you can't do that but
illegal go to jail I also um did just to
be clear volunteer to pay him to open
for him on this tour he's planning do
you know he has an app
really uh-huh he has an app and he's
trying to go on tour and I was like I
volunteer his tribute to open for him
wow I know I don't know what's gonna
because I think most people are gonna
come don't you think just attack him and
make it weird
I just think it would be kind of amazing
to do stand up for a crowd that was
about to kill a man yeah
I would be like so what's your plan guys
what are we doing yeah like let me just
see like I mean it's just it's such how
do you bring him up do you list his
credits or do you listen to this
I'm gonna drag him I don't know I'm
gonna drag him and drive I don't know
but I just am like fascinated by the
fact that like people I just want to see
the kind of people that are going to see
him and is it for real or just to
yell at him
I feel like people throw Jello like I
just want to be there I would I mean you
would the people that if you're gonna go
yell at them it's like those people just
shouldn't go you're like just don't go
like and that like no one wants to go
see it and I would imagine maybe some
old like there could be some people that
are older and just loved Cosby and they
like didn't even know what had happened
they only read like USA Today yeah they
could be like I don't know if he you
know whatever they think whatever I mean
is he might go into these shows or he
hasn't said where he's going to do it
right he's was remarkable
when Joe Paterno and the Penn State came
stuff happened Joe Paterno died
immediately it's unreal that Cosby is
not it's actually pretty it's insane it
shows the kind of it almost shows the
person because I think it's a no sign of
a remorse Joe Paterno it I mean he
ate him alive it just was like do you
think Psychopaths if they don't feel
empathy they don't feel compunction I
mean how I mean how's he not died just
if he didn't do this how's he not died
yeah that's a good points like he's he's
very old I mean I think a lot of I mean
money keeps you alive I think longer and
I think there's also this Warrior spirit
in this will like Cosby like what he did
with his the sitcom is incredible I mean
it's an incredible show I mean do you
remember when they panned out to the
audience and in the finale I think it
was and they panned to the live studio
audience I mean Martin is my number one
sitcom he did some I think even more
Innovative stuff but I remember he would
like run out the window and then on the
crew would follow him out the window but
there was
they were just look trying to chase him
to get him back I mean by Seasons like
three actually because you know he um he
and his co-star like wouldn't be it's a
you know famously known that uh they
wouldn't be in uh the same room together
and uh they would only do like one or
two you could tell it was like only one
take because Martin would go out of the
frame and then come back in and they
didn't reshoot it like it was just it's
just like Bonkers and then one of my
other favorite things to do is to watch
Martin and not watch Martin at all and
only watch everybody else like trying
not to laugh while he's doing shit
because all the actors are just like
because it's so funny like all of all of
his guy friends in the show they were so
like in every scene but
Cosby
Stay With Me
what he did was bad but
like what is going on with you that you
wanted to have sex with America's dad
awake
yeah you meaning figuratively not me you
know what I'm saying I just because
you're asking me that question Whitney I
didn't want to talk about it but all
right I guess we will he's saying if you
if he hadn't drugged you you were just
gonna be like yeah like hahaha like what
was the draw of well it's it's it's the
it's the power it's the it's the power
of it do you think I think that we also
think why right he doesn't need to do
the drugging like you're like I think he
the that's what I'm saying do you think
on some level like the tenth woman that
was just like you know can I can I sit
on your lap and you do you know what I
mean or something like like I just think
there's something going on with being
attracted to America's dad at that time
it but there's it's it's also just a uh
I would imagine you need to look at your
shit too yeah yeah there it could be but
you're trying to get a hit or like
you're something it's either the fame or
it's like I don't know if he's on the
road or if it's like it's the the hope
of he's going to help you or it's the
feels like you need to call your dad and
work some shit out like I think you need
to you know call your dad and let him
know he dropped the ball yeah yeah no
nothing to this no no I agree I think it
look I have a daughter and I I think
very much so that I want to teach her uh
to be able to and not saying that they
did but really try to you got to be
aware of your situation especially for
women women it's it's just uh dudes can
be awful and they can be a motive and
just be and so it is too though you know
but no women can't do but I've got to
watch your wallet too sometimes yeah
yeah you got to watch who you marry
without a prenup but I want her to be
able to I want her to be able to handle
stuff on her own yeah there is certain
where you go you put yourself in a
situation that you should have never
been in that situation which is karate
karate is I can kill you with one hand
but I would never put myself in the
situation in the first place yes and so
some of that yes it is that what and
then but as long as she's growing up in
the South I think you're fine she's
running but but it's girls around big
around animals yeah like well obsessed
with horses let's go yeah I know so we I
do I do a Gala it's basically Equine
Therapy with uh girls and they learn to
like claim their space it's not about
what you're saying it's about how you
say it so when know when I was growing
up and going on dates with boys it was
like stop no stop uh you know because I
didn't want to let them down or hurt
them or embarrass them you know I was
also taught that like I truly was taught
that if a man got a boner when you were
making out and you didn't somehow
relieve the blue balls like they would
pass away there was this like guilt of
like if you started it like someone's
got to finish it yeah that's a lot like
they'll just be like oh you got I can
and you're like okay so like but horses
you can't
um you know you gotta say like no and
you have to mean it and horses respect
that so it's a way for them to learn
that you don't go like no thank no like
no because when you do that you're
hoping the other person is just gonna
make the right choice and like read your
mind but if your body is not body
language isn't congress with what you're
saying you know well I like that then
yeah so it's super cool I'll show you
what we do with horses because oh yeah
she's obsessed she works at this horse
camp
Mission she was like six and they she's
a leader uh leader in training and she
leads uh people come to birthday parties
she leads them on the trail ah so cool
she's 10 years old oh you have no you're
you don't have to worry about anything
yeah but also sort of the medicine of
being around something that like wants
nothing from you uh and learning how to
uh basically like not be needy and uh
fear driven because like our energy like
you know you walk into a room and then
everybody responds to your energy and
you're like why is everyone being so
weird yeah you did that yeah but like
horses hold a mirror up to you and show
you what kind of energy you're giving
off and show that you have made you have
like like I basically just had to learn
how to be a leader of people you know
it's like when I was working on the you
know made these shows I all of a sudden
had like 400 employees and I'm just like
20 I don't have no idea what I'm doing
and my leadership style at the time I
didn't know any better was like just be
friends with everyone and like talk
through their stuff and like you know
like what's going on with you like are
you doing okay like do what like can I
get you anything like I just was like
wanted love from everyone I was working
with and they just wanted to get out at
five yeah you know what I'm saying so
the best thing I could do for them is
just like all right we're shooting again
I can't do it right now we're gonna move
on love you action instead of like how
are you doing I just feel like a weird
energy are you okay like I was trying so
hard to take care of everybody but the
best way sometimes to take care of
people is just to be really direct and
clear yeah and fair it teaches animals
horses prey animals they teach you how
to be fair I like that idea with that
when you're saying like with uh yeah
when you have when you're running a show
like when you're running a show and you
had all those people it's like yeah they
it's they want you to be nice to them
but then it's also like yo I'm not your
like best friend in the world like I
just I'll have a home they have to uh
they they're like I have a two-hour
commute yeah you have like a 10 minute
commute yeah and I have like like you
know I have kids my you know I don't
have the health insurance you have see
that's the thing that with that the
disconnect of like a lot of with TV and
how like that that I feel is they don't
think about that kind of stuff and they
don't realize eyes like when you think
of news or you see social media and
another part of it is the people that
are making
TV and what everybody sees they are
addicted to social media so they only
see social media yeah and they and so
then that's their energy is like a news
person goes on can you believe what's
that and it's because they're addicted
because all they have they have the most
time ever just to go and flip through
then they in television shows put famous
um internet people on their TV shows
thinking they're famous and interesting
but America is like who's the fuck is
that like I don't know what that is it's
very hard that people talk with like
Fame like do you want to like to be you
know if you're uh Jimmy Fallon or James
Corden like that's how the power of
power of TV they too talk about it too
like they want to go to followers a
network is still gigantic like if you go
a network television I still believe is
gigantic but you know how Sports they
make their money well football is is
but you're on the commercials during the
football game like that stuff matters
I'm on a fox show right now called the
accused and it is excellent Howard
Gordon he did 24 he did Homeland you
know but you know taking it it was like
doing a show a network show it was like
yeah if it's on Fox they have football
yep that's the show you know what I mean
like that's gonna do well I still would
have done it you know but then it's
gonna go to Hulu but like you know most
of these networks like are owned by you
know like I mean universal they don't
make their money off TV shows it's like
a side silly side hobby one syndicated
TV show Friends is still is what what's
paying everybody's bills but why do they
make like if they do you think I mean
they I'm sure they try to make friends
again but like
is it that hard of a formula to crack
like to make something yeah these days
are so fragmented and there's so many
choices so it's like friends today it's
like friends is is brilliant you know
and next Generations are finding it so
they also friends did this incredible
job of you know uh it down to the
costume was made for syndication right
so not a lot of topical references okay
they dress like German tourists if you
go back and look at their wardrobe
everything is still in style in a weird
way they were khakis jeans t-shirts like
very smart uh TV shows don't Syndicate
as well if they're single camera and if
there's like you know because the idea
is like you know people are like well I
want to wear this and I want to wear
this and I want to like look super
fashionable but then in four years this
is going to look dated yeah you know
whereas like friends still feels classic
so Two Broke Girls you know we made it
in a restaurant where the two girls are
in uniforms most of the time so in 20
years it's still going to feel it's
going to be fun yeah you know well and
you think it's also the people make
stuff for family viewing I have like the
I think viewing is very divided so it's
like shows are made for you know the
wife the husband the kid not there's not
a lot like get America's Funniest Videos
yeah it's like a family can watch that
shower that's like yeah YouTube now so
it's it's hard maybe for syndication
because you're like well it's not going
to be the quad viewing that they say or
whatever you said America's funniest
videos now we like have world star and
we can watch a human being get like shot
in the face like Trader Joe's whatever
we want yeah but I watch we watch
America's Funniest with our daughter so
good because it's but it's like saying
like we would watch remember when
someone would do a backflip into a pool
that ended up being empty and the sound
effects was like and you're like I think
that person's like gonna walk weird like
forever oh yeah like that sometimes we
wouldn't have to go hey this person's
fine they have to say it after because
because it's like so I mean there was a
couple times people like just I feel
like there were a lot of dads getting
like baseballs to the dick and you're
like I don't know if he's gonna like did
he kill the kid after like what happened
I wanna I wanted America's Funniest
Videos like where you see the hospital
visit out yeah okay we're about to talk
about Etsy y'all like oh okay I feel
like so we're I'm working with Etsy uh
they are now have finally I have conned
them into
um being a sponsor on the podcast I
don't know how this happened
838 purchases
on Etsy
I think this is in like the last like
month or something I love to shop on
Etsy for the most like unique
beautifully made items from independent
sellers you know that I'm obsessed with
vintage clothes I'm obsessed with
um uh handmade stuff unique stuff Etsy
sellers have everything from statement
pieces like rugs and sofas I have many
of them daily Staples like outerwear and
accessories you can get jackets jewelry
Furniture art and more made all for any
budget and occasion you know what else I
love about Etsy oh my God you get like a
personalized no they'll be like Whitney
thank you so much for shopping at my
store and I'm like yeah girl like I'll
be back soon if you're new to Etsy use
the code new for 10 off your first
purchase that's code new maximum
discount value of 50 offer ends June
30th 2023 see terms etsy.com terms for
Home Style gifts and more job at
etsy.com I'm so happy I've never been
happier this is just I'm in heaven
okay so oh by the way did you ever see
um Bill Cosby leaving the courthouse uh
yelling hey hey Fat Albert oh no okay so
this is important
this is why he's he's still alive I just
want to answer a question this is him
leaving the courthouse uh and
watch how
like
um he thinks about doing this to
entertain his fans and then how he does
it okay it's so bone chilling this is
him leaving the courthouse I think after
he was
[Music]
[Applause]
uh yeah bummer yeah that is why he's
alive though because it's like I mean he
just doesn't there's no but that's a guy
that's been famous for you know uh I've
always fast if you've ever been famous
for that long and they they have no
sense of any sort of I just try to do a
joke like like Tom Cruise like I I like
Tom Cruise like Tom Cruise is someone
that makes stuff for America that's why
Top Gun was gigantic Tom Cruise yeah yes
because top because he he makes stuff
Mission Impossible he makes stuff for
people that are gonna watch he makes
movies that have guns in them yeah
that's always that hard guys that's all
we want not that hard
there's no one watching our shows
there's no guns
there's no guns in movies that's why
people go we have to go buy them because
we just want to see people go pow pow
but you won't do it so we have to do it
at home like it's just like movies
forgot what their job was yeah I don't
know that's why people go buy guns
well I have a theory yeah you walk at it
just like some sad movie and you're like
I gotta go shoot some guns dude I would
know why people buy guns I am a woman
many people want to kill yeah yeah yeah
every man
every man or been with
has begun within two
when it's about over he goes what are
you doing wit that's what they call you
go wait wait
and you're like they're good they're
telling my real name are you insane one
of the biggest skills in life you can
have and this is something we do in
Equine Therapy and um uh something that
next time I come to Nashville I'd love
to like see where your daughter does
what she does and we can maybe like
um talk about like the ways that you can
put people in categories not as the
stereotypes not as like being reductive
but just to go like for me my main
requirements like before I let someone
in my life you can call it like red
flags whatever
if they didn't play team sports
like people to play team sports I just
get along better with them you know uh
only are you an only child
only children are like I just like I
know I know a lot of them that I love
very much I just don't want to
collaborate with them my daughter's only
child yeah well is another one coming
but no yeah we'll see maybe you'll be so
you won't collaborate so you're gonna
come to that you just told me you would
work with her now you're telling me you
want to come there and go I'm sorry I
can't work you see what I just did we I
like literally do horse Behavior like
yeah he's like a horse you know but if
okay but if an only child plays team
sports or works with horses you or grew
up on a farm okay okay so she's at home
a lot of cousins a lot of rounds a lot
of family as long as we live in a
cul-de-sac she gets beat up by other
family kids yeah yeah I'm saying yes if
she's alone and there's no other
children like
um you know giving her Wasabi saying
it's guacamole you know what I mean yeah
like that kind of thing yeah yeah like
she is able to fist fight other children
yeah okay what else is it okay it's only
child Pat what's my other one
only child team sports
vegans like generally on a cleanse I'm
not on a cleanse you can't be on a
cleanse like at work like you came out
and cleanse around me I just don't try
and then people who go I've never drank
and I don't drink
you know those people like I've never
had a hit a pot and you're like why not
just have one and like you know what I
mean does that make sense you know those
people yeah like I've never drank once
yeah I never will you're like you're not
even gonna so everyone's wrong
but you're you know like have you ever
done a like show this happening one time
at the comedy store and I just like had
to like kind of snapped like I was
working on new stuff and it was actually
going really well and it's very rare
that I'm like oh shit this is like
feeling this is like cracking like in
the in the or in the comments yeah do
you ever go up the comic store over here
uh a little next time yeah but that or
is like it's like flying like when you
were able to get them like the sound the
way that Mitzi Shore built it like the
way the lights are like you can't see
them at all but you can really like feel
them and when it's like you know that
dark everyone feels permission to laugh
even harder because they know you can't
see them so they'll laugh at crazier
shit but it takes us you know but then
you're like following Sebastian or
you're following you know a killer so
you have to either surf their energy but
usually have to you know it's just like
the most fun yeah yeah it's like surfing
it's the most fun thing in the world
when you catch the wave and anything
less than catching it you want to die
but you know I was on one night it was
like I was like felt like I was like
flying and there was this one guy in the
front who just was like not feeling it
and I just like so everyone's wrong so
all these people yeah are but you're but
you're in your like you think they're
all wrong like do you ever have that
moment yeah yeah
when you're like I don't get it well
it's hard to not focus on that person
too so they're dumb so they're just dumb
yeah like it's just this weird thing
yeah where it's like why can't I only
focus on them you know what I remember
right so I did the Byron Allen thing uh
Comics Unleashed I did that once but
then the other the comedy.tv and you
were actually the host
uh
yeah you would never remember like it
was big there was that's where we filmed
all day I think it was a hundred shows
in five days it was crazy yeah it was
like 10 in a day or whatever over two
weeks yeah so that was like so I
remember when I did that that audience
was like because they would sit there
and they just were like there was real
no reaction and I had by four I was like
are you guys ready like that are you
guys oh it was everyone's just like on
fentanyl yeah yeah because they're there
for the 50 bucks I mean it's like I used
to do uh uh said in audiences for money
when I was broke back in the day I mean
it's just like a nightmare like they're
literally like shaking with the DTs
waiting for their cash and I remember uh
They're laughing at the wrong part like
they're not even really listening and
then uh and I remember one guy with a uh
he had like kind of a big afro and I
remember he just sat there and just
stared the whole time and that's all I
could see and it was all the faces and
it was a guy that was like this is not
worth 50 like it was just he's been
there the whole time and so the whole
time you're up there I'm just looking
and he's not I mean and it was just and
he was so like just just over it and
you're you know they just try to go like
well Something's Gotta make him but it's
it's he's not even have you ever um done
the Galas in Montreal I did the um the
Montreal Gala uh it was uh Steve Martin
was hosting the ukulele and the Mini
piano and like the all the stuff and it
was the like five o'clock Sunday one
yeah it was me Catherine Ryan orny Adams
oh God I'm probably forgetting who else
but I went out there and it it was the
five o'clock Sunday show it's an opera
house so it's like people that have
season tickets to the Opera yeah and
they just come every Sunday but it like
it just happened to be an evening with
Steve Martin so they thought they were
going to see like banjos and like you
know like I don't know what everyone is
bombing in a way that's like everyone
was like is this we were literally
saying is this thing on we're like can
you guys like should we like we everyone
that went out there they're like we
don't think they can hear us and
everyone's like no no the mic works yeah
this is it was like every it was also
light like we could see every person
there was some in the front row uh like
an old couple that after every joke they
would check in with each other and be
like
like they would check in with each other
and give like uh it was like it was such
a nightmare and then um ornie Adams went
up last though
and fucking killed yeah it was one of
the wildest Things I've ever seen like
no one could crack it and we were like
uh oh this is really gonna put orney
over the edge yeah like we should all be
waiting because he's gonna put a gun in
his mouth after this you know what I
mean because he's just like a bull and
uh you know what I'm saying and he's
like goes out there with like a spiky
ass hair like an animal and starts
yelling about customer service in India
and just starts destroying and we're all
like okay this is all of a sudden less
funny that we all bombed because yeah
he's so funny dude
kills me like that was one of the like
coolest moments I've seen in comedy when
I went you know what it's never the
audience's fault yeah yeah it's not
because that was the night that I made
that like we all were like oh well the
audience is just like whatever like that
they don't get it they're dumb and then
he just went out there and fucking
ripped whereas everyone else was like oh
well everyone's bombing so I'm just
gonna go bomb two and like fuck them
yeah you know and just destroy it bless
you sorry are you allergic to have
you're having your time wasted uh before
Before I Let You Go Okay
um so your specials now on Amazon can I
just ask it like I went to the app put
in your name it came right up to find a
Netflix special now you have to like
um go to grad school to learn how to
search in a you have to be a woman
what's her mother's maiden name
can I ask why you decided to do Amazon
uh
uh so uh Amazon was very excited at
Netflix you know I've just changed my
life and then Amazon uh started work
with them and then they uh because I'm
only asking just because I'm curious
like because because people are like
well why isn't it on Netflix like for me
I kind of want to diversify I want to
have some on Netflix some on Amazon you
know well Amazon's starting to get into
uh they want to make a big push in the
comedy
all Jim gaffigans now right yeah and so
they're uh they they were very much
wanted me to be a part of that nice push
and then they were going to be way
behind it with the advertising and they
were very very excited to do it and
sometimes I'm like I just I'm curious
what you guys are going to pair me with
you know users who bought this item also
bought pregnancy tests but I can own it
too yep so that was I paid for my last
one so that was that was a a big thing
uh Netflix I wouldn't have been able to
own it and this one I can't own it and I
I really want to know this one yup yup
and then so you paid for it yourself yep
and then did you find yourself being a
little bit like of a slumlord or because
for me when I paid for my last one I
actually went all out and I felt like
when someone else was paying it for it I
was weirdly cheaper so I was like well
this isn't even mine yeah so I mean like
you know it's like owning a house like
you're gonna put more into Landscaping
than if you're renting yeah yeah that's
yeah yeah I did this was definitely the
most expensive special I've done because
it was in the round and everything it
looks so good yeah they it they did
great but we knew where was going we
already it's like we already had the
date we are at everything planned before
we uh
knew where he was going to go and then
doing it in the round can I just ask
like did you do a couple shows before
because I remember Dane Cook used to
doing the round Louis I think shot here
and Carlin right and Carlin and so did
you look at their specials to see how
the coverage works because in the round
I'm always kind of like someone's always
like missing something like how did you
I just yeah I'm just always kind of
chasing pacing around and so I like it
because it helps me with my rhythm and
it helps me with my pacing so the whole
time I was just doing that because
otherwise I always Pace back and forth
yeah fucking lying in a case well I
that's why I like going around and I
think you're moving around enough that
no one's really even really thinking
about it and then you're I mean you know
you have to maybe sometimes if you when
you make a joke you may have to stretch
your face real expression a little bit I
also think something magical about the
round and obviously the greats before us
that you included uh know this is It's
the audience gets to see the other side
of the audience they get to see each
other yeah so I had them lit so Harlan
special is with just the lighting set up
back in 78 or whenever he did it you can
see that the audience is lit up a ton
and so this so when I saw it I was like
I want this audience to be lit up and I
want you to be able to see them the
whole time because my last special was
in Universal covid mask and you can't
see the audience I remember I wanted I
wanted to show people having you were
like having a fight with helicopters oh
yes yeah so this one I wanted to like I
want to show people have fun I wanted to
show people how to show having a good
time and like to see people behind you
it's just so fucking cool yeah it's it's
nice to yeah I think especially after we
went through it's it's nice I mean I
honestly it's like I could see where
you're like I might shoot them all in
the red like they just looks so good
they look so good I also I love proof I
know it sounds silly and I think it's
because I come from multicams and I got
accused so much of like this is a laugh
track this is canned laughter like
that's how you know dysmorphic people
got you know where is it was like most
of the shows like how I met your mother
was actually laugh track there were a
lot that actually were and then we were
shooting live but we were Comedians and
you know I didn't know to not have
microphones in the audience like I
didn't know yet in order you know to do
a sitcom you know you should never do
the joke you want in the show first you
know because if you do this by the third
take they already know the joke so
they're gonna laugh soon yeah yeah so
for me sometimes like when I'm doing
specials and I'm like that sounds like a
really big laugh because they don't know
how many people are in the audience like
I don't want them to think like this has
been sweet I don't know I just I get
paranoid about it so I love the idea of
like seeing the audience I mean like
they're laughing like you can't argue
with this those are human beings like
we're not sweetening shit I think people
have just started to kind of like not
trust
um laughs or something and I think that
like I'm doing the roasts you know
editing the roast which I know I begged
you to be on the Bert Chrysler one yeah
yeah
um I will uh uh con you into doing
another one at some point but um but I
even because to me it's like
you know when you're live like if
something deserves 20 seconds great but
someone that's at home
I'm always like how long are they gonna
how long are you gonna really laugh at
someone if you're not with like your
family and friends yeah you're gonna be
like Ah that's a great joke oh my God
I'm gonna text my friend holy shit next
joke yeah whereas then like I watch
these specials where I'm like I laugh at
a great joke from a comic and now I'm
just watching a bunch of other people
laugh and clap for like 20 seconds like
you gotta cut it out or show the
audience yeah this way there's no
cutaways because it's you're really just
showing on yourself so it's like I think
the round is like this is the way to do
it I think people were so mad at Dane
Cook for so long yeah that they just
like were like we can't shoot in rounds
because that was what he did or
something yeah and then he got then cook
was great yeah I mean yeah I was a big
thing cook for me too I used to open for
dinner I used to open for Dane Cook on
the road we went and did a arena in
Sunrise Florida everyone's like getting
cook isn't funny I'm like I
look we don't get to decide oh no he was
the most funny he was the first company
that got kind of took down with like
almost like he just got too big and then
everybody just started like trying to
yank him down yep yep yep but I mean
you're like I mean that guy was uh great
he was super I mean he would destroy and
you know I never understood it it left
it all comic and then comics and people
that want to do Comics would always
trash it he's like then you go do it
dude if it's so easy then go do it yeah
why aren't you if he's so dumb and
unfunny what's your excuse yeah I went
and did uh these Arenas with him a
couple times and like when he came out
you couldn't like he had to wear
earplugs like people had posters like
kids had posters and I was like
this is what we all wish we could do
yeah yeah well like he did it like Dice
Clay did it he did it like it was people
screaming he would do bits everyone knew
and do him again like the whole thing
with stand up is you can't do a bit
you've already done they would call out
to say like do the cashew bit like do
this and he'd do it and they'd do it
with him yeah that's that's what a
musician does like Greatest Hits yeah
like can you do greatest hits ever I bet
you could I bet yeah I don't but they
have I've had people yell out I usually
can't remember like Chrysler's machine
yeah he does them I have a hard time
remember him that's yeah that's the hard
part because you just when you start
writing new you're just kind of so
focused on that so it's hard to remember
them so new tour Happening Now happening
now yeah Nate bargatzi dot yeah yeah do
you have any cities oh it's it just
doesn't stop it's uh
I don't know we did 200 something like
two dates or something less like it's uh
and it just doesn't stop we're I'm just
in it like it's uh you know it's all
everything's kind of it's going great
and everything so you just kind of like
just like do you ever bring your
daughter yeah she's we're going to
Europe next week
we're gonna come to Europe dude in
Scandinavia no no we're doing maybe no
not Scandinavia I never know what really
Scandinavia by the way neither do I I
just said that just try to keep smart I
was like I hope he knows what that means
yeah he's like Norway Sweden Finland
then I am doing skin okay
and like are you gonna shoot this at all
like uh like a documentary series no I
don't think so we someone mentioned it
once but it's like uh you know I've been
gone so much and then so it's and I've
got to do shows there that I just want
to like I would like to kind of see your
parts Unknown
yeah I wouldn't mind doing something
like it possibly but this one I love
watching really smart people not be able
to do easy things because the smart
people that made them made us feel dumb
yeah like I like watching smart people
try to figure things out that make no
sense yeah
like I feel like you do that a lot
yeah but I'm but I'm good at like like
you're able I'm sorry you're able to say
things like when you're like this thing
didn't work or like the gun place in uh
was that in Omaha you know like it was
like you it was like you just said it in
a way that was so simple but only
someone really smart could say it that's
how Louis you remind me of Louis CK in
that way don't you think
um yeah
I hope so yeah I mean to me I I feel
like so much like there's so few people
that can be that smart and then uh try
to do something and point out how stupid
the thing is am I making any sense yeah
yeah no that makes sense I don't know
what to say about myself like I don't
know how to but I mean I appreciate
neither do I I mean do I does it seem
like I know what I'm saying but I'm
trying to I just I don't know I'm such a
fan and I just I'm like trying to figure
out how to say what you do in a way that
the the fans can kind of go oh yeah
that's the not giving away the magic
trick but you're so like authentic and I
think that it's just like I don't know I
just I learn a lot from you about just
being a person well thank you just like
you're okay with silence you'll just let
it be silent the other Wings sit there
I'm a big fan of you as well and I love
everything I almost like the TV stuff
it's like I just I love how much you
know and think about that stuff it's a
skill no one needs any more I feel like
I have all these yeah
I think they do and I think they will
and I and I honestly I I think uh
they're starting to realize that even
now like you have like Night Court is
that multicam it's doing good yep you're
watching this I mean there's a point
that you're seeing a lot of this stuff
switched back to like the Hollywood
aspect where they're making shows where
you want to go you know other the people
in the middle like the the country are
like yeah we're not like I'm not gonna
keep watching like just me being dumb or
me being we're all racist we're all
right none of us or anything why are you
guys lecturing me you guys are the
pervert pedophile racists that did all
this you know what I'm saying like we
and you know it's really interesting you
say that because it's like it really is
Hollywood is like okay so you guys need
to stop being transphobic everyone's
like huh we don't even have time to be
transformed like what that you guys did
that you know what I mean yeah you know
I think that's such a great way to put
it but also in terms of like um the TV
business because I really think it like
in like super super business-wise like I
don't look at it as a hobby I don't look
at it as like a fun you know
um thing I just look at it straight as a
business and if you're gonna make money
in television the big ways to make money
is Court shows like live court shows
scripted Court shows people like justice
they like seeing idiots go fuck her he
told stole my plunger I want my fucking
because that's like everyone has that
shit you know what I mean relatable and
then they want someone who is uh an
alpha who's gonna go both of you shut
the fuck up like Judge Judy like breath
of fresh air going you're both fucking
children you're both gonna pay six
thousand dollars to fix your neighbor's
fucking lawn goodbye yeah you know what
I'm saying they want to hear someone
reasonable yeah tell childish people to
like shut up so you're getting like
justice out of it you're getting comedy
out of it you're getting um the ability
to feel better about yourself you know
what I mean I like to go like hey guys I
did this dumb thing and everyone goes oh
God I'm like I'm not so dumb yeah
because this person that I thought was
smart did something dumber than me you
know it's like you're giving people that
you know it's not just me people are
dumber than me and then another way uh
uh football is you know the biggest
Money Maker sports like we TV is
literally uh exists because of you know
footballs what keeps everything alive I
think it's stuff that can be co-viewing
also multi-generational viewing but also
most people watch TV as the fourth thing
they're doing yeah right unless you're
sitting and binging something like Ozark
or whatever Mad Men most people are
watching multicams and they're cooking
dinner and they're dealing with their
kids and they're changing a diaper
they're cleaning the house and they're
doing laundry and they need to be able
to just like hear a joke I got it and
then I can go in the other room come
back I still get what's happening you
know and that's why you want three sets
okay they're in the diner got it I
already know what's happening you know
yeah that's why you're making TV that
it's like I don't have to it's not a
whole thing that's when you watch like
uh like Ozark for me I did not watch
Ozark and I know it's great but it's but
I just got to watch a Breaking Bad so I
watched Breaking Bad it's Ozark against
two weeks of your life like you have to
You'll watch it like when your wife like
leaves you I don't know when you would
have time yeah yeah I'm just waiting for
that and then so then it's it's uh but
it was like two like it was like such a
big thing to watch Breaking Bad then
you're like all right Ozarks are you're
like I can't do another like whole thing
like and that's how a lot of the TV
feels like now Netflix a lot of the
shows are like I can't do you know what
show kind of started that and I'm happy
for someone to challenge me what show
started that that kind of like addictive
viewing Sopranos great great guess
I think it was 24. oh yeah remember how
24. was like what the fuck dude what and
they were just like because it was it
was all in an amount of time that made
urgency viewing like how do you get
people to watch a show tonight
instead of like I'll get to it when I
get to it yeah it's very hard to do you
have to make something that's addictive
and that makes people produce adrenaline
you know so it's like the best comedies
now you know are the ones that have
something kind of dangerous in it like
raw me or something that's gonna make
you feel adrenaline because that's what
makes you addicted to something yeah you
know and I think that like usually I
mean like Chris Tucker dude
that guy
he was like comedy but the movies made
adrenaline that's what makes the biggest
comedy Stars they're in some kind of
action situation yeah yeah yeah you know
so it's like it's just like it's I just
like boil it down to like where you
could go the opposite there now I think
that's why people watch old stuff now is
because you don't see racism
dude my favorite show to this day is
married with Children yeah dude it is
the most sexist in against men and women
yeah between people like the show sex is
against women I'm like have you seen
what the men do like you look like King
of Queens you're like that is so sexist
like Leah remini's just the setup like
uh Kevin James like can't read like I
think that's the joke he's so dumb he
like can't use like a dishwasher like
this is sexist against women I'm like
it's pretty I would say that my podcast
I get made fun of so that they would if
I went through and like and I I'm just
like I killed I can't read I'm so
trouble reading that's my invert there
is like stuff that you do or like my
stand up something if it's because you
got to learn the balance but then
sometimes it's like well if you could go
too hard on your wife or something
you're like well I mean you I just
listed a thousand things of me being the
stupidest person alive and then so you
balance but you do have to balance it
out and then you're like uh
um did we you know run out of salt for
the casserole and you're like you are
already pissed hold on hold on you know
so I think it's also it's like you know
in the South like it's just not like
that you know it's like we go at each
other and we go like you know the women
in my family in the South are much
scarier the men are terrified of them
too I'm saying so it's just like I don't
know this whole thing where um you know
it's like we're gonna Empower women by
acting like they're made of glass and
have to be treated like kid gloves and
can't take a joke like that's always
just like such that's why I loved
Rosanna Dan they were Savage to each
other like that's real love you know
Luke Bryan uh and uh Caroline his wife
they're two of my favorite people on the
planet they're in um uh obviously
Nashville and then um outside but uh
they just rip each other dude and they
have the most fun like their
relationship is just like they've been
together for so long and they just prank
each other they're just like as soon as
he wait a blowhorn in his face before he
wakes up in the morning I mean it's just
like that is the most fun to me yeah
yeah but if they they lived in Hollywood
Luke Bryan would go to jail for abuse
um anyway so do you think you're gonna
do a TV show and I'm just gonna keep
doing specials uh I'm trying to now
we're trying to we're trying to we're
trying to see what happens with one
really yeah yeah I mean I've tried it
it's been every year almost basically
tried and like I look at it now like I
would like to I still you know I would
love to make a Everybody Loves Raymond
Cosby Show that's your question like
when are we gonna I I know this is where
it's going
uh when are we just gonna go let's
Finance six episodes of a show
you can do it for yeah you can do six
episodes of a show
for 500 Grand yeah yeah if you want to
do like in that like it's like what
Tyler Perry did I'm a big fan of a tire
period what the blue collar guys did
they went We're not gonna pay La prices
for office space we're all funny as shit
we made money on the road why don't we
just go live but where are you you're
talking about like instill selling it to
a network and then you yeah I mean Rob
Schneider I think did it he tried to do
like a multi I think he made like 30
episodes of a multicam and then sold it
to Netflix but it's just like why
wouldn't you just own it because there's
no syndication anymore that's that ship
sailed you know and then some network is
going to go hey can we pay you 40 Grand
an episode and then we're going to hire
200 people like we're just that aren't
you know like it's gonna cost us eight
million dollars to make this but you're
gonna get 40 Grand an episode and then
we own it all so you can't even control
where it goes you know you've been two
years it's going to be on the al-Qaeda
Network you know and you can't control
it yeah or you know you just want to
make sure you like own everything yeah
you know and I think that it's like it's
like I think that like
um the blue collar guys uh Tyler Perry
are kind of the people to
no I agree The Comedians have to run it
yeah and and they've all you know
gaslate us into believing we're not good
at business and you guys sit at the Kids
Table we're the adults like you guys
haven't we're the ones making money
we're the ones that when you guys aren't
involved people show up to see us talk
yeah but when you guys get involved we
make no money I remember I did Ron White
his um he did a Comedy Central pilot
like 15 years ago okay and I was like
the correspondent on it just like the
dumb idiot he showed up every day to a
comedy central pilot I was probably
getting paid 500 maybe and he showed up
in a different Bentley every day we got
to like brown
like that's how many Bentleys he had we
got to like brown by the end he flew in
on a private plane to do a Comedy
Central pilot and literally he was like
I'm losing so much money on this fucking
television show I mean because he wasn't
touring and then ultimately they wanted
to make it but he was like I just can't
I can't make 150
000 a year I'm Ron White yeah you know
so it's like I just think that if
comedians are in charge we're gonna know
what to do that's the power that
comedians can have is they can show up
to television and go crazy brilliant of
business we we figured out a way to make
money from talking yeah we're great at
business yeah well comedians they can't
do budgets we can't yeah I had seven
dollars for eight years I can balance a
budget dude like so I just think that
like the only fans saying me being able
to run it myself with no Executives no
one that wasn't a comedian had any say
in anything yeah and it was like magical
yeah you know so it's like I just think
that like it's we just got to step up
and stop going like who's gonna help me
make my show it's like you can do it
good when bridesmaids came out remember
bridesmaids was like fucking massive and
then after bridesmaids came out I was
getting all these calls it was like Hey
can you write the next bridesmaids who
will you make the next bridesmaid it's
like we want the next bridesmaids like
how about like four girls like you know
on a work trip or like four girls on
like um
you know uh like a bachelorette thing
and I was like you guys are you guys
like do not understand don't emulate the
thing that was just successful the
formula of three girl of sorry four
girls being drunk and weird and whatever
emulate the idea of an original idea
yeah don't try to do what they just did
it's gonna be super obvious and you're
just basically like exploiting and
that's also you should have to pay
Christian wig and and Annie momelo for
that because you're stealing their idea
and just trying to put it in a different
location just make something original
that's what they did yeah yeah you know
so it's like we that's what we're up
against yeah you know yeah that is
that's the main thing because they're
just like ask for the same thing like I
think the less people involved the
better okay so this special on uh Amazon
the highest compliment I can get is it
made me incredibly jealous and angry wow
that's how good it is and I know how big
of a compliment that is I literally was
watching and I was like God damn I was
like fuck you like damn it
damn it huh thank you
all right I end these very awkwardly as
you can tell I love your podcast uh
listening to your podcast actually makes
me be less hard on myself because I'm
just like I think I'm a mess when I do
these I'm like you know what if you're
fucking with me you fuck with me if you
don't you don't yeah no you and you but
you know a lot I was quiet but I'm also
taking this stuff in like as you're I
think what you say is very smart well I
have so much I know but I know but he
has a lot to learn from you so well
let's yeah friends yeah let's people
speak bro let's be homies to be homies
you know what I'm saying yeah
um I love you guys uh you know where to
find them uh what a pleasure don't ride
elephants goodbye
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]